[MUSIC PLAYING]
DALE MARKOWITZ: Hey, I'm Dale.
This is "Making with ML."
And today I'm going to show you
how this adorable little fox is
the future of video
game interactions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So imagine you're playing
this sick new game where
you decide to visit
your local shopkeeper,
but the shopkeeper doesn't
have what you need.
What if instead of
selecting from a list,
you could ask for what
you want in plain English,
while the game uses
machine learning to come up
with a fitting response?
Or what about making
objects, like cats and trees,
more interactive, action the
game developers didn't even
consider?
Can ML expand the ways players
interact with the game world?
Today, I sat down
with Anna Kipnis,
a senior creative
technologist with Stadia Games
and Entertainment, and
we talked about how
machine learning can make
game worlds more interactive.
ANNA KIPNIS: In
my lifetime, we've
seen games go from very low
fidelity, like maybe two
colors, like "Pong" or
something like that,
to extremely realistic 3D.
So you know, the visual
development of games
has really exploded, but I think
that the interactivity is still
really lagging behind.
Like, we're not that far from
where we started, really.
And so what I'm
really interested in
is kind of closing that gap.
DALE MARKOWITZ: Why
is it so difficult
today to build a
game that supports
all of these rich, varied,
and spontaneous interactions?
ANNA KIPNIS: Right
now, the process
is that the developers
have to anticipate
what all the questions
that the player might
ask of their world.
Like, are they going to ask
about this specific weapon
or something like that?
What should happen as a
response to that, right?
So, at the moment,
the developers
have to account for
both the cool answers
that they can have in the world,
but also every single question
that the player might ever have.
What semantic ML
allows you to do
is that it allows you as a
developer to focus mainly
on the interesting answers.
DALE MARKOWITZ: The technology
Anna is talking about here,
semantic ML, is a way of making
sense of words or sentences
with machine learning.
Given a set of words,
you can use a model
to see which pairs
are the most similar.
For example, an ML
model can tell you
that a jetpack is more
similar to a flying broomstick
than it is to a garbage
can or an apple.
You can also use semantic
ML to help pick out
likely responses to queries.
So if I say, "I would
like some coffee,"
Semantic ML can tell me,
"here's a cup" is a better
response than "I hate ur butt."
Anna uses semantic ML to
describe her game worlds
in plain English and then
have a model infer how
the world should behave.
Let's take a look.
ANNA KIPNIS: I've
labeled objects
using English that may be
interesting for the fox
to interact with.
And in pink, you see
the sorts of actions
that the fox can do
on these objects.
It can predict, OK, of the
list that you just gave me,
if this is what the
player said or did,
it will be able to
rank them from best
to worst in terms of what
is the most likely thing
that somebody in
conversation might have done.
So, first, let's
say hi to everyone.
It waves.
And then let's see if we
can have some coffee here.
So it goes to pick up the cup.
DALE MARKOWITZ: So cute.
ANNA KIPNIS: Yeah, then
it brings it to us.
And the coolest thing is I
didn't program the Fox how
to answer these questions
or even, you know,
what the heck coffee is.
I just labeled that object
that kind of looks like a cup,
and I put it like a small mug.
That's just English words.
And semantic ML kind
of did everything else.
You can type sentences,
they don't even
have to be particularly
spot on, right?
Like, you can say, "sofa,"
and it will know it's couch.
I actually have
the system rigged
up so that you can just do them
straight up in Google Sheets.
And then you can try these
really bizarre things,
like get really stoked.
I get excited.
Cool, make some [INAUDIBLE].
Oh, whoops.
It conjured a painting
because I typed
"Monet" instead of "money."
And you know, this
thing actually
has cultural associations.
And so it understands
that Monet is a painter,
and so it conjured a painting.
So, yeah.
And so here now that
it's spelled correctly,
it creates a coin.
DALE MARKOWITZ: What
you just showed me,
it's exactly what you're
saying where like, you
as-- even as the person
that built the demo,
it's still surprising
and spontaneous to you.
ANNA KIPNIS: Exactly.
This is like what's
so magical to me
is that there is
essentially a way
to condense some
of these patterns
that people have
in conversation,
condense all of that human
interaction into a usable form
that you can have in a game.
To me, that's like,
it's essentially
indistinguishable from magic.
DALE MARKOWITZ: If you want
to learn more about the tools
that Anna used to build her
demo and how you can use them,
make sure you check out
the blog in the link below.
And let us know what you
build in the comments.
See you next time.